Frame rate is the key to making your
game feel smooth and responsive.
The faster you're able
to update the screen,
the smoother objects will move and
the quicker they'll appear to react
to collisions, bullets,
input from the player and so on.
A low frame rate,
makes a game seem jerky and slow.
The simplest game loop, gets input from
the player, does some game calculation,
then updates the screen.
The problem is that updating
the screen usually takes the most time,
so time the games behavior
to screen updates,
tends to make the whole
game feel sluggish.
A better approach is to keep
track of how long it takes
to update the screen each time.
Then use that value to predict how long
it will take to render the next frame.
Now, you can collect player input, then
update the game world in a tight loop,
perhaps a millisecond at a time,
effectively fast forwarding the state
of the game to that future point.
In effect, this approach allows you to
tie your game processing to a universal
wall clock instead of how
often the screen is updated.
The result feels smoother because
each frame is now a snapshot
capturing the game state as it
changes independent of screen updates.
This is such a common practice that most
pre-built game engines and development
frameworks will handle it for you or
make it very easy to implement yourself.